Speaker 1: Let's go back to the audience
on our discord if you'd like to call in,
you can go to David Pakman dot com slash discord.
Let's speak next to Harrison from California,
Harrison. You were on the air welcome.
Speaker 7: Hey, David, thanks for having me.
My pleasure. I didn't really come with a specific
question other than just to share frustration.
Not too long ago, actually, I think it was the
other night I watched a clip of yours or someone
asked about how your girlfriend communicates
with a largely conservative family, and it
resonated with me. I have both my parents whom
are separated. I have over the past six years,
been just completely inundated with the
conservative talk of the typical conservative
talking points, you name it, from Fox News
to, you know, Tucker Carlson, that Carlson to,
you know, my my mom who's always
been more conservative, but she has.
Turned into like she's just gone straight down
the rabbit hole to the point where, you know,
she sends me stuff and she's on like Telegram
with these IQ and on people, and I'm just,
I, you know, I try to say, like, look,
you need to get rid of this. She there's
no ability. She has no ability to tell right
from wrong. And I mean, the most ironic thing
is when I bring counterpoints up, she gives
my points more scrutiny and criticism than
the points that other people are telling her.
She just like accepts, you know, it's typical. I
expect it accepting the things that agree with her
and, you know, things that she doesn't agree with.
Speaker 1: Hey, let me ask you this what
what kind of what feel does she work in?
Speaker 7: She's she's been in sales
a lot, but she's like a chicken kind
of like the. Real estate kind of thing right now,
Speaker 1: it does she seem to have an ability to
think critically within the field of real estate.
In other words, when people make claims about,
oh, look, it looks like you've got a termite
damage. No, no, no, no, no, we don't. It's
fine. That's actually nothing like she's able to
discern that like people might be lying there or
does she generally is she generally naive?
Speaker 7: Generally, generally, I mean,
it's more of a like happy go lucky
person, and I mean, it's worked for,
you know, she's a kind hearted person like in
reality. But the one thing is, you know, she's.
Like a little bit of her background, her and
her family, my my parents and aunts and uncles,
grandparents ran away from communism
and from China. And so for that reason,
their whole journey to get to America back,
you know, in the 50s and 60s, like 50s and 60s,
really, you know, is what got them really
patriotic and really appreciate the country,
which is something that when I was growing up,
really, you know, made me kind of proud and and,
you know, stuff like that. But it always gave, you
know, my my family's pretty split half of it is
a little more liberal. Half for half is a little
more conservative. And she, like she does exhibit
a little bit of. Like critical thinking when it
matters, but I mean, at the same time, like I
couldn't, you know, if she went to take her car in
to get fixed, she probably got ripped off to tell
you the truth. Like, I'm usually have to be the
one to be like, Okay, wait, wait, wait. Like, does
this actually need to happen? I actually do this.
Speaker 5: Sure, sure.
Speaker 1: Maybe there's just the personality
predisposition to sort of accept what people are
saying in some way. And it's not just on politics.
Speaker 7: Yeah, there is a predisposition,
and that's why I feel like she's more of a victim
of the the whole, you know, narrative that they're
trying to pitch because she's definitely someone
when I was growing up, you know, the AM radio is
always on, always talking to like Rush Limbaugh
are like listening to all these shows. Yeah. And
she would come home from work and like the first
things out of her mouth was just, you know, Oh my
god, Obama is going to do this. You know this and
that? You know, they're going to try and take over
the country and don't like it's it's not that bad.
It's I've literally been sitting through 30 years
of the sky is falling essentially about, you know,
liberalism. And now I was in the Marine Corps for
four seven years. And so I, you know, I get the
conservative, you know, patriotic, conservative
sounding standpoints. And just only really over
the past like five years have I really just kind
of turned and been like, you know, there's really
nothing that. You know, insane that's happening
on this side like this. There are like crazy
ideas, but there's crazy ideas on both sides,
and the stuff that ends up getting
executed and signed into action really
are pretty mild at the end of the day.
Speaker 1: Hey. In the Marine Corps,
were there any progressives or
was it very, very conservative?
Speaker 7: It's it's largely conservative.
Absolutely. There are like I've met quite a few
like rational, level headed people, they might
still fall on the conservative spectrum and
but there definitely are like. I mean, it's
probably, I would say, some of the best
people I've met have been the ones that have
ended up being a little more like moderate to
liberal in like in political view. And that's not
just like me asking them, like, Hey, what are you?
But it's just their personality showed it, which
is what you know why we became great friends. And
then later on, I was like, Oh, hey, like, you
know, after getting to know them, like, Hey,
he's actually kind of, you know, rational thinking
in the military, but it's only a minority.
Speaker 1: Well, Harrison, you've really set it
all. I appreciate it sounds like a complicated
situation, but I wish you the best.
Speaker 7: I appreciate you taking
the time to talk to me. All right.
Speaker 1: Harrison from California.
That's quite a scene, that's for sure. I would not
that that's complicated. Let's go next to Pablo
from Albuquerque. Pablo, you're on the air. Can
you hear me all right? Just barely, Pablo,
you're barely audible. It sounds like you're
about two miles from your microphone, is there
anything you can do? All right, we're going
to have to let Pablo go. Unfortunately,
we've never had a caller so, so quiet.